oh that almost took off my head this
needs some context Nikko really wanted
to throw a GoPro off a bridge let's
rewind it definitely breaks this GoPro
when it comes off the bridge
I'm going to throw it off the bridge
he's going to catch it the $200 throw
right now
[Music]
basically we take this thing and we're
going to try to shove a GoPro inside of
it but I don't exactly know how to do it
plan of attack is to figure out where
this GoPro is going to sit so that with
just chopping off the nose it'll cover
the outside of the GoPro without
covering the lens there is my don't put
the GoPro pass there point I guess so
that unfortunately didn't cut it super
straight as I think that's okay or less
bit
[Music]
people tell you how well the work
oh great now if I was to undo that spin
I'm gonna have to go through frame by
screen it's actually not that tedious of
the process about sewing at 60 frames
per second so I slowed that down to like
40% speed filming at a higher frame rate
means that you can slow down footage I
kind of think that 60 frames per second
isn't fast enough because look at the
extreme rolling shutter we're getting do
you want to go do it super quick super
quick 120 fps it should not be too faces
it hit the ground so hard it's tough to
clip fairly certain the GoPro still
works
but what happens is that recording to a
memory buffer and then offloading that
buffer onto the SD card and when you cut
it it just it saves the files to the SD
card as it is like snipping it off and
it doesn't continue recording well looks
like we're shooting the video in
experimental form alright you planned I
wanted to get a risky little shot we're
gonna drive across the bridge I'm going
to throw it off the bridge Jake's gonna
be down here he's going to catch it and
we're going to win the big game
will the Canadian tuxedo help me catch
the football we could definitely break
this GoPro it bah it doesn't get caught
when it comes off the bridge
well because 10 hours like I got after
yourself
[Music]
all right guys
about four seconds three two one
your way I hope it's still rowing
Hunnicutt so it's turning on again on
its own that's interesting that's
exactly the same problems we had any
more go profession yeah one more
girlfriend we assumed or the $200 throw
right now fight I missed I coulda taken
two like Benjamin Franklin and lit them
on fire whose orange glass vessel
alright in just your throw here we go
are you rego
the only thing I found that got out and
all I hear is is Nikko go all right here
it comes
and then I hear red heavy drive-by going
oh no around by you raise your bow the
car you go Willis this is not a turn-on
it's dude full turn on turn off flick
oh my god no we won't be able to shoot
that right so I don't think we should
get free shot
I mean arguably we can't shoot at all
well we haven't this is our last chance
this is our last GoPro hopefully we
don't kill this one too let's go to the
park and get some Beauty shots for this
video and if the GoPro still alive we'll
try the bridge again we've come to the
park because we think that if we do drop
it it will land on grass which will give
us a higher chance of it not breaking
and rooting this whole shoot we're going
to try a couple things here I think
you're gonna like first take first try
the classic hiking top red go along
[Music]
we're gonna take it to the next level we
could break down this one we're going to
throw it into the trash can we go I hope
you're watching classic
[Music]
Oh straight up hit the GoPro yeah
all right oh well that was pretty sweet
I think we got some really good shots
there I feel pretty confident about our
abilities now you know what that means
we need to go and try the bridge shot
one more time all right so just start by
going on the Greek isle identity think I
might actually like but you yeah my
suspension system can't handle this
apparently you break
well looks like what are yesterday's we
have to use this Bret you have to use
okay can you go as well yeah oh yeah i
frickin uh-oh Yanis break on get over
there ask you did you break on
there's groups - Bill Gross doing good
luck I'll do my best to do yours
together II play baseball and football
hope he doesn't under through it that's
the one I'm worried about if we won't
make it if it's way down there ready
[Music]
oh don't took off my head
Oh hippo it's still blinking nicely
well it sure is I'm going to start
rolling again
[Applause]
you took a chunk out of it now drawing I
didn't press me button alright let's go
we can do this just go for it we can do
we're asking to kill the goat just gonna
throw it a little bit earlier that's it
[Music]
you got it
aces yeah good luck oh hey sometimes you
got seventeen and you draw for ego after
we broke two GoPros we went out we got
some really great shots to the park we
got some really cool montage so we got a
lot of nice footage
I know Jake doesn't think I can make
this fail and he loses it can be buying
another one
oh is that perfect throw then we came
back here and we felt supremely
confident that the ridge shot we
accomplished we went out we tried it
again and we [ __ ] nailed it you did
it I'm proud of you guys if I got good
news for you guys
this is Tuesday we have 24 pounds worth
of gear coming from GoPro Christmas just
changed it's now February 28th oh my
Wayne would that's what all this is
ah